en uno de los vídeos pasados empezamos a
tener una intuición sobre las gráficas
de la rapidez contra el tiempo y sobre
lo que representa el área bajo la
gráfica de la rapidez contra el tiempo
por ejemplo esta gráfica representa la
rapidez de un automóvil y cómo cambia
con respecto al tiempo así que esta
curva nos muestra que la rapidez está
cambiando esta no es una gráfica de la
distancia con respecto al tiempo es de
la rapidez como una función del tiempo
por lo que podemos ver que el auto está
acelerándose en el tiempo de igual a 1
vamos a 10 metros sobre segundo y en el
tiempo t igual a 5 suponiendo que todo
está dado en segundos el auto va a una
velocidad de 20 metros sobre segundo así
que el auto está acelerando ahora la
relación entre la rapidez y el área es
que el área representa el cambio de la
distancia del auto por lo que la rapidez
en este caso es distancia por unidad de
tiempo y si somos capaces de con
el área bajo la curva esta área nos dará
nuestro cambio en las distancias desde
te iguala 1 hasta t igual a 5
no nos dicen nuestra distancia total
porque de hecho no sabemos qué pasa
antes de t igual a 1 así que no nos
preocupa esa área y la instrucción de
atrás es que es más fácil encontrar esta
área si la dividimos en rectángulos así
que hagámoslo sin tomar el primer
rectángulo empecemos con uno desde t
igual a 1 hasta de igualados ok
este de aquí que representa el área de
este rectángulo bueno es el área que
obtenemos al multiplicar un segundo que
es el ancho del rectángulo por su altura
que es aproximadamente 10 metros sobre
segundo así que las unidades serían 10
metros sobre segundo por un segundo lo
cual me da 10 metros de hecho sabemos
por los conceptos de física que se
multiplica la velocidad por el tiempo o
la rapidez por el tiempo obtendrás la
distancia de manera que las unidades de
esta área son de distancia
y bueno si quieres no
una aproximación sino la distancia
exacta es decir el área exacta bajo la
gráfica entonces utilizaremos la
anotación de una integral definida así
que esta área de aquí la podemos denotar
como la integral de 1 a 5 de la función
r dt ok esto por dt y una vez más que
representa esta integral en este caso
cuando la tasa de cambio es la rapidez
bueno pues representa el cambio en la
distancia
el cambio en la distancia desde el
tiempo te igual a uno hasta el tiempo te
igual así y bueno con este mismo
contexto qué te parece si intentamos
resolver un ejercicio del estilo de los
que encontrarás en khan academy bien
hagamos este que tengo aquí dice adam
camino con una rapidez de rtp kilómetros
por hora
ok ahora te está dado en horas que
representa la integral desde 2 a 3 de r
de t de t igual a 6 bueno incluso antes
de leer las respuestas quiero que veas
esta integral y observa que van desde t
igual a 2 horas hasta t igual a tres
horas y esencialmente está tomando el
área bajo la rapidez recuerda aquí la
función de la tasa de cambio es la
rapidez con una rapidez
dt kilómetros por hora entonces está
integral representa que desde te iguala
dos horas hasta te iguala tres horas
adam camino seis kilómetros extras así
que veamos cuál de las opciones coincide
con esto ok
la primera dice adam camino seis
kilómetros cada hora ojo
nos dicen que adam camino desde el
tiempo te igualados hasta te iguala tres
una cantidad de seis kilómetros pero eso
no significa que cada hora camino lo
mismo no sabemos qué pasó desde te
iguala 0 hasta te iguala 1 o desde te
iguala 1 hasta te igualados así que en
definitiva voy a cancelar la esta no es
adam camino seis kilómetros en tres
horas bueno esta opción sería un
malentendido común la gente ve el límite
superior este de aquí y dice ok esta
área que está representada por esta
integral nos dice que tanta distancia
hemos recorrido hasta este punto cuidado
no es lo que representa lo que sí
representa es el cambio en la distancia
desde t igualados hasta t igual a 3 así
que voy a cancelar también esta opción
ok
vayamos a la siguiente adam camino 6
kilómetros durante la tercera hora ok
esto me parece perfecto es justo lo que
hemos dicho desde de igualdad 2 hasta t
igual a 3 en la tercera ahora adán
camino 6 kilómetros y es justo lo que
dice así que voy a seleccionar esta como
mi respuesta correcta pero vamos a
revisar la última la rapidez de adán
incremento en 6 kilómetros por hora
entre las horas 2 y 3 ok vamos a ser muy
claros este 6 de aquí no representa la
rapidez estas 6 representa la distancia
es decir el área bajo la gráfica de la
rapidez esto es lo que nos dice esta
integral definida así que esto no
representa el cambio en nuestra rapidez
lo que realmente nos dice es cómo cambia
la variable a la que se le está
aplicando la rapidez cómo cambia esa
variable desde t igualados hasta t igual
a 3 así que no
también cancelar en esta opción y por lo
tanto me quedaré con esta opción espero
esté todo claro seguiremos en el
siguiente vídeo saludos